welcome everyone this is our first
screencast on information retrieval
let's start with some guiding ideas
these will serve both to give you a
sense for the current moment in science
and technology and also help you build a
bridge into the homework which is on
retrieval augmented in context learning
you might have noticed by now that NLP
is revolutionizing information retrieval
this is a story that really begins with
the Transformer or maybe more properly
one of its most famous spokes models
Bert soon after Bert was launched Google
announced that it was incorporating
aspects of Bert into its core search
Technologies and Microsoft made a
similar announcement with Bing at about
the same time and I have a feeling that
these two very public announcements were
just a glimpse of the changes that were
starting to happen with major search
engines
a little bit later we started to see
that large language models would play a
direct role in search I think the
startupu.com was really Visionary in
this sense and I like to highlight
you.com because it's CEO Richard socher
is a distinguished Alum of this course
and you.com was way ahead of the curve
in seeing that large language models
could be really interesting and Powerful
aspects of web search
and we've seen lots of activity in that
space since then for example Microsoft
has partnered with openai and is now
using openai models as part of the Bing
search experience and you might have
noticed also in a kind of different
perspective on this that when gpt4 was
announced part of the announcement was a
partnership with Morgan Stanley to help
Morgan Stanley employees use gpt4 to
find things in their own internal
documents and that just shows you that
we hear a lot about public web search
but there are also powerful search
applications that could happen internal
to organizations again powered by in
this case throughout this uh this entire
story as usual powered by the
Transformer
you might ask yourself why this is
happening and I think the fundamental
reason is that information retrieval is
simply a hard natural language
understanding problem and so the more
powerful our nlu Technologies the better
we can do with retrieval here's an
example that kind of brings that point
home our query is what compounds protect
the digestive system against viruses and
a relevant document is in the stomach
gastric acid and proteases service
powerful chemical defenses against
ingested pathogens
the coloring indicates relevance
connections you'll notice that for the
keywords in the query and the document
there is no string overlap the
connections that we need to make here
are entirely semantic and that shows you
that the more deeply we understand the
language of the query in the document
the better we're going to be able to do
at finding these relevant passages given
queries like this
so that's all mainly about information
retrieval but I'm an NLP here and for me
the more exciting direction of this is
that information retrieval is now
revolutionizing NLP and the way it's
doing that is by making our NLP problems
more open and more relevant to actual
daily tasks let me use question
answering to kind of highlight that in
the buy now standard formulation of
question answering within NLP the system
is given a title
and a context passage and a question and
the task is to answer that question and
there is a guarantee that the answer
will be a literal substring of that
context passage that is standard QA as
formulated in tasks like Squad the
Stanford question answering data set so
just to repeat at train time you're
given a title context question and
answer
and at test time you're given a title
context in question
and you have a guarantee that the answer
is a literal substring of that context
passage that used to be a hard problem
for our best models but it has grown
quite easy and I think you can see that
it's also pretty disconnected from
actual things that we want to do with
question answering in the world where we
very rarely get this very rich kind of
context or that substring guarantee
so we are moving now as a field into a
formulation of QA that I've called open
QA and this will be substantially harder
in this mode maybe there's a title and a
context and a question and the task is
to answer but now only the question and
answer are given at train time and the
title and the context passage will need
to be retrieved from somewhere from a
large document Corpus it could be the
web
and having retrieved it of course we
have no guarantee that the answer will
be a literal substring of anything in
the context or the title so this is a
substantially harder problem but it's
also much more relevant because this is
simulating actually searching on the web
where you pose a question and you need
to retrieve relevant information in
order to answer the question
but substantially harder only the
question and answer at train time and at
test time all you're given is the
question and all the relevant
information needs to be retrieved and
what you see there is to the extent that
we can have really good retrieval
Technologies find us really good
evidence for answering these questions
we can develop effective systems and
that is the crucial role for retrieval
in this open QA pipeline that you all
will be exploring as part of the
associated homework and bake off for
this unit
and question answering is really just
one example of a family of what you
might call Knowledge intensive tasks I
mentioned question answering but we also
have things like claim verification
Common Sense reasoning long-form reading
comprehension and information seeking
dialogue these are all transparently
tasks that depend very heavily on having
Rich information about the world
informing whatever prediction the system
makes so that's pretty clear but I'm
also interested in taking standard
typically closed NLP tasks and expanding
them into more open variants for example
summarization is standardly just posed
as a task where you take in a long
passage and try to produce a shorter one
but couldn't we make that a knowledge
intensive task where we augment the
input with lots of information that
we've retrieved I think it's a
reasonable hypothesis that that could
improve summarization systems
similarly natural language inference
typically just posed as a closed
classification problem premise
hypothesis and you give them one of
three labels but wouldn't it be
interesting to augment the premise with
information about the world that might
help the system make better predictions
as a classifier
and I think that's just two examples of
how we could take classical problems
even classification problems and
reformulate them into knowledge
intensive tasks that would benefit from
retrieval with the result that they
could be made more effective and also
more scalable to real world problems
let's talk a little bit about
information retrieval approaches and
I'll start with classical IR
in this case we have a user query coming
in when was Stanford University founded
and the first thing that we do is term
lookup and so what we've done offline
presumably is create a large index that
Maps terms to Associated relevant
documents it could be a list of
documents that contain the term but we
would probably also do some scoring of
those documents with respect to these
query terms to organize them by
relevance
on the basis of that index we can do
document scoring and give back to the
user A ranked list of documents ordered
by relevance and then it's up to the
user to figure out which of those
documents to check out in looking for an
answer to the question
that is the classical search experience
as we all know it
there is now a movement afoot to replace
a lot of that with pure language models
I've called this the llms for everything
approach in this mode the user's query
comes in when will Stanford University
founded a big language model totally
opaque to us does some mysterious work
and spits out the answer Stanford
University was founded in 1891.
a real change to the search experience
whereas before we had to look through a
ranked list of web pages to find our
answer now the answer is given to us
directly
that could be very exciting however
we might start to worry we know these
models can fabricate evidence and so we
should be skeptical consumers of their
outputs and since we don't know where
this answer came from we have no
information about how it was produced we
might start to wonder about whether our
information need was actually met
whether we should trust this string
and I'm deeply concerned about this
model enough that I think we should be
pushing in a different direction and
that's where you would get neural
information retrieval modules continuing
to be important players in open
knowledge intensive tasks for NLP
so neural IR models are going to
function a lot like those classical
models except in a much richer semantic
space we're going to start with a big
language model just as we did in the
llms for everything approach but we're
going to use it somewhat differently
the first thing we'll do with that
language model is take all the documents
that we have in our collection of
documents and represent them with the
language model
so the result of that will be some dense
numerical representations that we expect
to capture important aspects of their
structure and their meaning that is
essentially the document index in the
classical IR mode but now it's a bunch
of deep learning representations
then the user's query come comes in and
the first thing we do with that query is
process it probably using the same large
language model and get back a dense
numerical representation of that query
and then on the basis of all these
representations we can do scoring and
extraction as usual so at this point we
can reproduce everything about the
classical search experience the only
twist is that scoring will happen in a
different way because we're now dealing
not with terms and scores but rather
with these dense numerical
representations that we're accustomed to
throughout deep learning
but the result of all that scoring is
that we give the user back a ranked list
of pages and so we've reproduced the
classical experience for the user in the
sense that they now need to search
through those pages and find the answer
to their question
we just hope that we're doing a much
better job of offering relevant pages in
virtue of the fact that we're operating
in a much richer semantic space
this is a good moment to bridge into in
context learning which is the other part
of this unit and they'll all come
together for you in the homework so
let's think about how that bridge is
going to happen now we're going to be in
the mode of having a large language
model and prompting it and in this case
we've simply prompted it with a question
who is Bert and the task is to come up
with an answer in the mode that we're
operating in that is the only thing that
we're given by the system this is a
truly an open QA formulation so the
question is how can we effectively
answer this question using retrieval
well one thing we could do is retrieve
from a document store a context passage
for that question that we hope will be
relevant evidence for answering that
question so that's given in green here
but there's more that we could do with
retrieval for example we know that large
language models when they're doing
in-context learning benefit from having
demonstrations so maybe we have a
trained set of questions and we could
just retrieve from that set a question
to use
and then at that point we could either
use the training answer to that question
or maybe retrieve an answer in the hope
that that will more closely simulate
what the system actually has to do but
in any case we now have this
demonstration and we could go on further
depending on the train set we could
either use training evidence like a
passage from our QA data set or retrieve
a context passage again using a
retriever to function as evidence for
this little demonstration here and The
Guiding hypothesis is that having woven
together training instances with some
retrieval steps to produce evidence for
answering this question we're going to
do a better job at coming up with
predicted answers
that's a kind of simple retrieve then
read pipeline where we're using our
retriever to find evidence which you'll
see in the in context learning unit and
as you work on the homework is that this
is just the start of a very rich set of
options that we can employ for
effectively develop in context learning
systems that use retrieval to find
relevant evidence that's how these two
themes really come together
and I think that these two themes coming
together is one of the central questions
for the field of NLP and IR in the
current moment because really what we're
seeing is a lot of worrisome behavior
from large language models that are
being deployed as part of search
Technologies for example we all saw that
Google took a real hit in terms of its
stock price for making a minor factual
error in one of its demo videos
maybe that was appropriate given how
high stakes all of this is but it's sort
of funny to think about because at the
same time open AI models were
fabricating evidence all over the place
this is a sort of amusing example where
I have asked the system our professional
baseball players allowed to glue small
Wings to their caps and I asked the
model to offer me some evidence for the
answer that it gave and it did indeed
dutifully say no and then offer some
evidence but the evidence links that it
offered are entirely fabricated they are
not real links to web pages if you
follow them you get a 404 page I find
this in tremendously frustrating and
easily worse than offering no evidence
at all because we have all become
accustomed to seeing URLs and assuming
that they do function as kind of ground
truth evidence for the answer given so
the fact that that ground truth is being
completely fabricated is absolutely
worse than offering no evidence at all
here's another funny case for this we're
going to talk about our demonstrate
search predict paper and figure one of
that paper includes an example with the
question how many stories are in the
castle David Gregory inherited
on Twitter a user read our paper and
then tried the example with a Bing
search engine and they said aha you know
Bing can answer your very difficult
seeming question no problem but then
that user immediately followed up by
noticing that Bing was actually citing
our own paper as evidence for the answer
to this question I will say that this is
deeply worrisome to me our paper should
not be regarded as as good ground truth
evidence about the castle David Gregory
inherited we used it purely as an
illustrative example and if we had had
slightly different intentions we might
have actually been talking about giving
the wrong answer to this question in
fact our figure does embed some wrong
answers and so the idea that a
scientific research paper that's about
in context learning with retrieval would
be used as evidence for the castle David
Gregory inherited anything about that is
completely baffling to me and that just
shows you that simply because you have
some search mechanisms doesn't mean that
you're doing good search but what we
really need in this context is high
quality search
and just to round this out I found this
amusing but maybe a little bit worrisome
you should all try this with your own
names I prompted chat GPT with write a
biography of Christopher Potts from
Stanford University
I'm very happy with the first paragraph
it's very flattering to me and we can go
ahead and say that it is truthful but
everything in the Box in red is
completely false all of the factual
information expressed there is false and
it's kind of a nice biography of me I
have no complaints about any of these
facts except that they are false and the
reason though that I'm worried is that I
think not everyone is going to get such
flattering information when they ask for
their biography and we are just on the
precipice of seeing really worrisome
Behavior with really meaningful
Downstream effects for people in society
if these language models continue to
fabricate evidence in this way and
that's why I feel like the current unit
and the work that you do for it is
absolutely extremely important and
relevant to addressing this growing
societal and technological problem
that sets the stage if you would like a
little bit more on this Omar mate
zaharia and I did two blog posts on this
a few years ago that I think remain
still extremely relevant the first is
building scalable explainable and
adaptive NLP models with retrieval
that's a kind of technical blog post
and a more high level outward looking
one is this modest proposal for
radically better AI powered web search
where all the way back in 2021 we were
emphasizing the importance of provenance
for information and ground truth in
documents as an important aspect of
doing web search even with big powerful
fancy large language models and that is
the vision that we're going to try to
project for you throughout this unit and
with our homework